[Music]
I'm the one
so if you're somebody that's wondering
what's still going on with Ukraine and
Russia or even the Wagner group that
recently created some Ruckus in Russia
as well as the military-industrial
complex we have the right guest here for
you today Douglas McGregor Colonel
Douglas mcgregory retired army colonel
and government official and author
consultant and television commentator I
believe you've written five books the
most recent one margin of Victory five
battles that changed the face of modern
war he played a significant role in the
battlefield in the Gulf War and in 1999
NATO bombing of Yugoslavia in his 1997
book break in the Phalanx established
him as an influential if unconventional
theorists of military strategist his
thinking contributed to the U.S strategy
in his 2003 invasion of Iraq after
leaving the military in 2004 he became
more politically active in 2020
president Donald Trump proposed McGregor
as ambassador to Germany but the Senate
blocked the nomination on November 11
2020 a pentagon spokesperson announced
announced that McGregor had been hired
to serve as senior advisor to the acting
Secretary of Defense a post he held less
than three months Trump also
controversially appointed him to the
board of West Point Academy his alma
mater he is loved by many but he is
hated both by the left and the right
some would say the establishment he's
also the EVP of Burke McGregor group
thank you so much for being a guest on
the podcast yeah thank you so why are
you pissing so many people off what's
wrong what's going on there Gene I
thought it was popular yeah he was
really shattering to me you're popular
but some people are sitting there saying
why is why is this guy got these weird
opinions and strange opinions well
anybody that Washington likes these days
is suspect inside the United States
let's put it that way so I'm happy to be
unpopular inside the Beltway so it's
almost like a compliment nowadays I I
think it's a tribute yes so so we we got
a lot of things I want to go through
with you on today's podcast obviously
your background your expertise when
you're getting calls from people asking
how do we handle this issue here in Iraq
how do we handle that and you're given
the most unique perspective where
everybody else is saying the same thing
you're given something else one has to
pay attention to your strategies but
let's start off with Ukraine Russia when
it first got started
um you know you were one of the ones
that said this is going to be done in no
time it's almost done it's going to be
done it's going to be done in a week
it's going to be done in a month it's
going to be done in two months it's
gonna so a lot a lot of people felt the
same way as you but you were one of the
main spokespeople that kept saying this
is going to get that why is it still
going on today and it's been as long as
it's been no I think that's an important
question and it surprised me as well as
lots of other people by the
by the way the Russians went into
Ukraine their their initial operation
was very different from what anybody
anticipated
and I think President Putin went in with
the following objectives remember he's
been talking for at least 15 years about
his opposition to the movement of NATO
to his borders
he's made it very clear that he regarded
it as a threat one of the reasons he
moved into Crimea was that he saw that
becoming a NATO Naval base principally
for the U.S Navy obviously in the Black
Sea
so he moved on that first and then said
look I it's got to stop well what
happened of course is you know is we had
the coup in Kiev where now the
ukrainians call it Keith
and as a result we installed a
government that was prepared to do
essentially whatever we wanted them to
do and we poured billions of dollars in
very early to build up an enormous
Ukrainian military force whose sole
objective was to attack Russia
and it wasn't very long before Putin
concluded that if I don't act soon I'll
have missiles sitting on my border that
will be able to reach my Nuclear
deterrent in no time and Rob Russia of
any sort of security at all
so he decides to go in but I think he
thought at the beginning and this was a
false assumption that he would have
someone to negotiate with
so he said I'm going to go in really
initially with only about 90 000 troops
organized into small contingents he gave
strict orders that they were to avoid
collateral damage at all costs didn't
want to kill anybody he knew he was
moving into an area which was largely
Russian anyway
but he also didn't want to kill
Ukrainian forces at that point he said I
want to demilitarize the place but he
said I don't want unnecessary casualties
on the Ukrainian side and remember from
his vantage point
these were also Slavic cousins Brothers
whatever you want to call them and the
Russians felt that way I think initially
so he moves in with this very small
Force he encounters a lot of resistance
I think the resistance is exaggerated in
the sense that the Russians have never
taken heavy casualties
but nevertheless he encountered a great
deal of resistance but most important
when he met with people for negotiations
he discovered there's no willingness to
reach an agreement because Washington
principally is in charge
Washington doesn't want an agreement I
mean he can read the tea leaves and the
tea leaves are very clear this is
Washington's opportunity to quote
unquote bleed Russia
in addition to bleeding Russia once
we've bled it we're going to see Putin
and his regime removed and ultimately
then we'll think about what we want to
do with Russia to include stripping it
of resources breaking it up into smaller
parts whatever
this of course was a horror story that
he had not really believed it and he
found out gee I was wrong and so by the
summer he has a meeting with all the
senior officers and they say look we we
wanted to go in hard you told us to go
in soft we wanted more troops you said
no now we're in the middle of something
we're not going to end this conclusively
unless we build a larger and more
decisive force with the right
capabilities and so
you had this change in strategy that
says we will consolidate control over
what we've got which is about 20 to 22
percent of the territory where most of
the Russians but not all lived where
most of the resources are too by the way
and we will run essentially an economy
of force Mission our strategy is to
build an unbreakable Fort and then let
the ukrainians expend themselves against
it and then when we're ready we'll take
the offensive
and that's effectively what's happened
and the ukrainians have expended
themselves they are now at a point where
I would say there's practically nothing
left anybody who is really trained to do
much is dead or wounded
it depends on which source you want to
trust but it runs from 250 000 dead up
to three hundred thousand dead to 350
000 dead on the Ukrainian side and
that's military force not yeah that's
just that's just the soldiers that's
just soldiers now I don't know how many
civilians have been killed and I'm very
very suspicious of that because
despite the change in strategy that
resulted he has always been unwilling to
kill quote unquote innocent so if he
strikes something or you see President
Putin yeah so if you see a strike going
somewhere as we did quite recently the
objective was to kill Frankly Speaking
foreign forces that were billeted in the
Hotel this included U.S UK and others
because he's been warning everybody in
NATO get out
if you don't get out you're going to be
at risk and then of course next to it I
guess was a school or something and so
immediately the ukrainians say see the
Russians are killing people in schools
you know we went through this repeatedly
where the ukrainians would set up uh gun
positions inside hospitals schools malls
and once that happened the Russians had
no choice but to destroy those gun
positions which meant that they were
inevitably attacking what were formerly
only civilian targets I mean this is not
new we've been through this in the
Middle East we've experienced something
similar
so the bottom line is that now we're at
a point where the ukrainians really have
expended virtually everything they've
got
they're now talking about mounting one
last
counter-offensive I don't know how
they're going to do it whatever they do
it won't succeed they have no chance of
breaking through Russian defenses in the
meantime I think we've had a certain
amount of unrest in the senior ranks of
the Russian military because a lot of
the senior officers want to attack and
end this war
and they're very concerned about a lot
of what senior officials General
officers in the in the Russian army the
senior generals so so then there's a
misalignment between Putin and his
leaders well I don't know if I'd call it
a misalignment as much as Putin is still
reluctant to take decisive action to end
the war quickly because he's concerned
about our predisposition to intervene
the great fear from the beginning has
always been that once it became clear
that the Ukrainian position was hopeless
there would be pressure in Washington to
intervene to rescue what's left
we almost have to protect our 150
billion dollar investment it's almost a
if you think about it it's like it's
like hedging if that does happen hey
we're so in it now that we said once
we're not going to send them tanks if we
do it's going to be this now we're
talking you know planes and all this
stuff we almost have to defend Ukraine
now well I I don't think so but uh I'm
sorry from the bidens administration
yeah well your argument actually uh
Probably sounds more like how we got
ourselves into the first world war but
the bottom line is with with this crowd
right now they've expended enormous sums
of money
so I'm sure there's pressure from
BlackRock and Raytheon and others
somebody told me the other day there are
only three branches of government in the
United States now one is Blackrock one
is Raytheon and the other is the
Pharmaceuticals
so there's some there's some Tragic
Truth to that since the hill is a
basically owned by donors and we have
government by donors the American people
really don't have much of a voice and
they don't know much about it so they
don't say much about it
but the truth is right now the
ukrainians are are on the on the ropes
there's no doubt about it and there's
this discussion I think behind the
scenes do we just move now and end this
thing decisively because they can
or do we wait some more and let the
ukrainians expend some more time and
effort and now you have discussions in
the west about a joint polish Lithuanian
intervention into Western Ukraine and
that's exactly the sort of thing that
the Russians have been concerned about
and that could never happen without us
without us authorizing it supporting it
and encouraging it and Putin knows that
so we're to kind of crossroads right now
in terms of what's next and the Russians
have to make a decision well there's
there's a lot there I'm sorry Tom I just
there's a lot there uh that we covered a
few things so
from a strategist standpoint okay you
know the the world when they think about
who Putin is you know former KGB this
guy is going to be a shrewd guy he's
going to be 15 steps ahead or he's going
to identify his next 5 10 15 moves so
you're gonna sit there and say if we do
this that guy's gonna do this if we do
this or we're going to push NATO to want
to move quicker to support them if we do
this maybe it's going to be easier to
take over a part of Ukraine that we want
under Biden not Trump because it's
I'm I'm picturing him as a guy that sat
there with his generals looking at every
single possibility that could happen
how did he miss the ball on hey let's go
soft on this it's going to be fine
they're going to cave in we're going to
get him in no time his military guys say
no let's go hard that's a big
miscalculation there on his end isn't it
well I think President Putin you
mentioned his KGB background one of the
things that people do not understand
about the KGB is that the individuals
that served in it were practically the
only people in the Soviet Union that
were allowed to travel beyond the
borders of the Soviet Union
that meant that they could travel in the
west Bhutan was very familiar with the
West particularly with Germany and by
the way he likes Germans speaks pretty
pretty good German
because I listened to him in his
interviews so from his standpoint he saw
a West that he thought they could work
with they could deal with and he's
always been criticized inside Russia for
taking that position
because I would say the mainstream
Russian position is you can't do
business with the West the West is our
implacable enemy that will never change
we are Russians we are not part of
Europe we are not part of the West I
think Putin took a different position I
think he thought that Russia should be
part of the larger European concert and
should have a role in the west well he
turns out his critics were right and he
was wrong now he's still a very popular
leader because he has improved the
standards of living Prosperity he's
restored a lot of Russian national pride
and dignity I think his latest poll
unofficial poll that we get out of out
of Russia puts him at about 89 percent
approval whereas Biden is at about 30
percent
so I think uh Putin is very secure in
that sense now
but he has always struggled with his
idea of how far do I want to push it
because Putin is is a smart man he says
when this is over
we want to live
with the Europeans and we want to live
with the United States we never thought
about that during the second world war
there were some people who did because
we did enormous damage to Japan enormous
damage to Germany was just one of the
reasons we had to stay there for 50
years and there were a few voices admir
Leahy who was effectively the chairman
of the Joint Chiefs at the time for
Roosevelt brought in the generals and
said look you're doing terrible things
to these people we want to be able to
live with the Germans and the Japanese
when this is over
well we didn't pay too much attention to
that but Putin is taking a different
position and he has also made it very
clear that this is Russia this is not
the Soviet Union and the Russian
military contrary to what the ukrainians
have been claiming have not committed
atrocities all over the place they have
not murdered and raped and pillaged in
other words this is not Stalin's Force
his slave Army of 1944 and 45. Putin's
made that very clear he still wants to
get along quote unquote he would he
wants to avoid a direct war with the
United States and with NATO
that drives much of his behavior but as
I said now he's at a point where he's
got to make some decisions
and that is what do we do do we continue
to move slowly and deliberately and
watch as the polls and lithuanians
presumably backed by the United States
intervene in Western Ukraine
is that what we do or do we act because
what he doesn't want is whatever is
remains of Ukraine when this is over he
wants that to be neutral he doesn't want
it to be militarized he doesn't want it
to be a platform for attack against
Russia he views Ukraine the same way we
viewed Cuba in 1963. we don't want it to
be a platform for attack against us we
still don't
and that's his position now can he
achieve that if he stands by and allows
the polls the lithuanians or anybody
else even U.S forces to move into
Western Ukraine I think the answer is no
Colonel is the position you just
described very eloquently on uh
President Putin is that the resolved
view that is in front of President Biden
is that where the Joint Chiefs are or
are they taking a different View
what I do know is that the senior
officers in the Army in the Pentagon I
can't speak for the other services but
certainly the Army had made it very
clear
that we are in no position to wage
conventional war against the Russians
and they're are they presenting what you
just presented as Putin's attitude and
position with that I I doubt it simply
because if you try to present that
position to the people who are really
running the government they are so full
of hatred and animosity and antipathy
for Moscow and what it represents to
them
that no one will listen
so they're I think they're they're they
have what we call ideological blinders
on so is that why there is so much
willingness if that is a prevailing view
that's being propagated not only to the
President's Day Late you know threat
report I assume and to the president
himself then is it any surprise to you
that senators or green lighting billions
of dollars for Ukraine because it's to
defeat this evil not to not to go Middle
East on you but to defeat this evil
Satan that is the old USSR Russia well
remember part of the problem here is of
Putin's own making at the beginning
because of the way he went in it
conveyed to the West this notion of sea
the Russians aren't serious they're weak
they're weak they don't know what
they're doing and then we flooded the
Airways with all of this propaganda
about the Russians are stupid and they
describe the Russians exactly the way
the Germans described the Soviets during
World War II which of course was
nonsense I mean I I was in graduate
school and Soviet East European studies
so I'm very familiar with it and they
literally lifted phrases and things out
of books that had been written about the
Soviet Army in the end of the second
world war and they were hurling this
crap at the Russians and and everybody
in the west of course was eager to
believe it remember we have the Cold War
behind us so it's not very hard to say
you know the Russians are really bad
sure oh yeah yeah right they they were
bad a few years ago so they must be bad
again that that's part of the problem
but Putin went in he was he was too easy
and it looked as though he was weak well
now everything is turned around you've
got about 750 000 troops focused on the
western military District in Russia in
other words the Western theater
about 350 000 in the south
now where are the other four hundred
thousand well some of them are tied up
in logistical support infrastructure
some of them are in missile uh rocket
artillery batteries some of them are up
in Russia some of them are just in
Western Russia
the the point is that this is an
enormously powerful force now with all
the most modern equipment and Technology
I think even the the biggest Skeptics
are shocked and surprised at the
Precision the accuracy and the
responsiveness of Russian missile and
strike assets for people who are
listening who don't have a map in front
of them when you say the Western theater
of Russia you mean the Eastern also
border of Ukraine right there and South
human Crimea I'm talking about I'm
talking about in southern Ukraine the
area which is referred to by the
Russians as novel Russia this is this
stretches from basically Odessa all the
way up to karkoff most of that is now
under Russian control with this force of
three quarters of a million yes
so okay so let's go let's go back to uh
thinking
trying to think what Putin was thinking
about so let's go soft instead of going
hard what what's what's the advantages
of going soft so for you as a strategist
to be fair I mean you know when you're
saying you know how you would do it and
what you would do you have a PhD I think
in international
uh uh relations from University of
Virginia if I'm not mistaken so
if if what is the advantage of going
soft are you going soft because you're
thinking that guy's gonna cave okay fine
so let's flip it what is the advantage
of going hard right off the bat where
his soldiers are saying no uh we have to
go strong with these guys to get what
done what's their argument of going hard
instead of going soft
well first let's be clear about the phds
and degrees you know thermometers have
degrees and you know where you stick
those uh I'm not I'm not disparaging my
PhD I'm just being honest there are a
lot of people walking around with
degrees that don't know anything
in fact I would argue that most of them
don't amount to anything they don't
produce anything they're not
practitioners
I focused when I went to graduate school
in military matters because I'm a
professional Soldier and it was my
obligation I thought since the American
people were funding my education
to focus on Military Affairs and
specifically at that point on the Soviet
Union and to a lesser extent East
Germany and Poland and general Slovakia
those are those are the areas where I
focused now having said that
again it goes back to a set of
assumptions I think that Putin if you go
back and look at his willingness to
negotiate
there was a point during the first three
weeks when the negotiators met that
Putin said I will immediately Embrace a
ceasefire
while these negotiations are on
and they stopped the Russians stopped in
their Tracks Of course people in the
west said well that's because they're
logistically unsustainable and all this
but that wasn't true
he was sending a signal I'm serious I'm
willing to negotiate
and remember that the whole thing
revolved around the Minsk Accords nobody
in the west pays much attention to those
Accords but they were signed by Germany
France we backed them and we promised
that the Russians who live in Ukraine
would be treated as equal citizens equal
before the law along with ukrainians
they would not be pressured to become
Ukrainian as long as they were good
citizens and obeyed the law they could
speak their own language go to their own
schools go to their own church and so
forth
that was a big lie as it turns out and
Angela Merkel who was the German
Chancellor was the first to come out
publicly and say we lied that was just a
buy time for Ukraine to build itself up
into the military power that it has
become
subsequently macron admitted it was a
lie so even after having been lied to
prolifically about all the things that
were important to the Russians uh he
decided I'll call a ceasefire we'll see
how these uh talks progress well the
talks didn't progress and then suddenly
we had this man Boris Johnson who flew
in as as effectively a surrogate for
Biden and said stop
don't give up anything and that was
because solenski had said sure I think
we could live with neutrality actually
made that statement which was the end
goal as far as Putin was concerned we
wanted to be neutral in other words you
have this nice large neutral State the
size of Texas that lies between Russia
and NATO gosh that's a good thing in
fact back in 1999 and and 1998 when I
was the director of
The Joint operations center at shape
headquarters Supreme headquarters Allied
Powers Europe these discussions went on
and somebody said well what's ukr
where's Ukraine in all of this and
everybody said Ukraine's mission is to
be a nice buffer
you know don't don't fight there don't
go there let them be a nice buffer
between Russia and us I mean that was
widely viewed as a positive thing
well that was thrown out of the window
and instead Boris Johnson says we will
back you to the hilt we will give you
everything that we possibly can your job
is to go out there and fight and we'll
back you and eventually we will be
victorious the Russians will collapse
Putin will be gone etc etc etc
none of that's happened and today Russia
is stronger I would argue economically
than it was before the War Began our
sanctions have been ultimately quite
helpful to the Russians they they are
not a part of our Western Financial
system to the extent that they might
have been hurt by us seriously how have
the sanctions been helpful to Russia
well they've managed to sell all of
their Energy Products all of their
minerals everything agricultural
products through others at higher prices
that have ultimately reached their
target destination in Europe and other
parts of the world anyhow so the amount
of hard currency if you will from the
West that's pouring in has actually
increased at the same time they've
discovered that they could sell
virtually everything if they needed to
to China
and India to a lesser extent those two
countries these are over a billion
people in each country enormous
economies they want to do business with
Russia so that the absence of the
European Market Per Se has not churned
out to be this terrible experience that
everyone in the west assumed it would be
wasn't that a chess game a lot of people
saw coming because both India and China
cannot self or will never be
self-sufficient on energy
well I suppose so uh you know I don't
know that anybody regarded as a chess
game because the difference between
Putin whatever mistakes he made
in terms of assumptions
shrink to insignificance next to the
mistakes that we've made I would argue
because we made assumptions about Russia
that were just completely wrong as just
like the rest of the world number one
Russia is a backward economy that will
collapse quickly if we sanction it in
other words that they're not a true
nation state in the western sense they
don't have a developed economy they
can't survive yeah we regarded it as
some sort of Mega Island yeah yeah they
don't have a real scientific industrial
base now suddenly we see all of these
factories
uh in Russia running 24 hours a day
seven days a week producing ammunition
weapons missiles all these things we
said they were going to run out of very
very quickly and couldn't replenish
we said that no one would support Russia
that Russia would be isolated well in
fact I I would argue that most of the
world actually backs Russia against us
that we and the Europeans are
increasingly on an island all by
ourselves
and Russia is not going to fall apart
Russia has become more cohesive this is
a state that rests on the foundation of
Orthodox Christianity and Russian
ethnicity now there are plenty of people
inside Russia who are not ethnic
Russians those people are treated very
well they are treated as equal Partners
inside Russia all you have to do is look
at the churches
you know and the chechens are brilliant
Soldiers by the way I keep hearing
people say Well they're not really that
good well you could not be more wrong
those people are superb and they are
fiercely loyal and by the way if you go
back to the czarist period every czarist
Army had contingents in it that were
kazakhs uzbeks chechens others turkic
peoples tartars working with them and
fighting with them against whomever the
enemy was whether it was the Ottomans or
the austrians or whomever
so the point is that Russia is more
cohesive than we are if you're looking
for internal unrest discontent divisive
forces you can find those in Spades
inside American society but that's not
the case in Russia at all so when you
when you look at the economy wise one
may say yeah they're doing better today
but even prior to the ward they had a
big birth and uh death problem I don't
know if you've seen the numbers on their
birth and death rate if you want to pull
that up that's not a a good look the
closest thing you can compare that to as
a case study they're having more people
dying than being born there's only one
other country can compare this to you
know who that is it's one of their
allies it's China those guys have the
similar issue India is a complete
opposite
and we're not doing that great ourselves
but uh Russia is not a good place when
it goes it comes down to that but I want
to go back to the thought wait a minute
before you leave yeah Putin agrees with
you yeah and Putin has tried very very
hard to reverse that he the first thing
he tried to do is to prevent The Brain
Drain everybody with any Talent OR
ability had been getting out of Russia
since 1992. so he's tried to reverse
that I think he's had some success he's
tried to encourage people to have help
by the way if you if you don't mind how
did he do the first one I'm curious
basically by finding employment for
scientists and Engineers that otherwise
had nowhere to go he said oh we've got
to find employment for these people so
that we can keep them here we have to
reward them for their talent I think
he's done reasonably well there when it
comes to the rest of the economy you
know turning around this attitude that
why should I bring two or three children
into a world that's dominated by
alcoholic men that are destroying
themselves and committing suicide has
turned out to be pretty tough I think
he's made some progress there I think
this war is going to help him enormously
because I think the war is Awakening A
sense of Russian identity that is far
far stronger and greater than anything
we thought existed all you have to do is
talk to the people that are inside
Russia and ask Russians what they think
everybody says well they're all afraid
of Putin so they're not going to tell
you the truth that's not true that's
just not true and we're hearing as
exactly what I said Russia is closer
United more today than I think it has
been in at least 30 years or 40 years
okay so so then as a as a competitor
whoever you go up against you're going
to do better
if you
put them as being overly calculating
meaning it's it's naive to just say it's
a simplistic War let's just do this this
is what's going to happen we're going to
be this right okay
you know for me sometimes you know how
an enemy uh forces you to do something
to come out and say see I told you this
is what they wanted to do the entire
time so for example I want to get your
feedback on this so I you know NATO is
trying to do whatever they can to get
Ukraine to be part of NATO no that's not
what we're trying to do no that's
exactly what they're trying to do and
this is why they promised us they would
never do this and now they're going to
be doing this nope that's not what
they're doing so he's pushing pushing
pushing pushing pushing and then all of
a sudden you know the article comes up
from Guardian if you want to show that
article real quick I think it's Guardian
uh uh you know which one I'm talking
about NATO accelerating the membership
uh NATO allies back Fast Track
membership for Ukraine says cleverly U.S
foreign secretary says Ukraine has
evolved quickly as zelinski tells Summit
it can be engine of green growth so all
of this time that they're talking about
this this is now leading to you you know
we have to use this as an opportunity to
bring him into NATO then Putin is going
to come out and say well I told you guys
this was the entire intention the entire
you know this is why I'm doing XYZ
because I knew you guys were doing this
is he that calculating of a guy that is
forcing his opponent and his enemy to
expose their hand or is it just
accidentally that this happened because
he didn't think the war was going to
last this long
yeah yeah I do and uh I think the man's
highly intelligent
and I there is no doubt in my mind that
he views what you just said as a welcome
development that the his opponent is
essentially revealing his hand saying
this is what we're really all about
but I do think at the beginning he still
thought there was a degree of Good Will
in the west that he could exploit
and there is none that's what he's found
out unpack that
I think because of his experience uh
watching various administrations
remember he met with bush
he is subsequently met with Obama and
and ultimately with Trump each time he
was be trying to understand us trying to
understand what we were about and I
think he listened to what was said in
private and he convinced himself that
these people really aren't the enemy
you know they are unreasonably obsessed
with or fascinated with NATO
which he doesn't see any reason for
I mean quite frankly he you know since
he had one of the things that's very
funny is people say well he was going to
invade Eastern Europe well wait a minute
you told me back in March that his army
was small and incapable
and now you're telling me he was always
going to invade I mean which which is
it's a bunch of nonsense so he wasn't
going to invade he wanted to do business
with everybody badly because he knows
that if Russia is to continue to develop
and grow he needs technology
most of the technology that he wants is
in Germany so Germany is enormously
important to Russia and always has been
well now he's turning away because he's
trying to substitute uh Chinese Indian
and other economic powers for German
cooperation
but the bottom line is that I think
Putin miscalculated up front there was
no good will he thought there was and
now he knows it so what are you going to
do about it Mr Putin and I think the
Russians are all standing around saying
okay we like you you've done a great job
uh you know the Army is ready it's up
and running it's now large enough and
strong enough to do what needs to be
done Mr Putin what are you going to do
yeah and you know makes sense we're
gonna see how much of that was you know
wasn't expecting that he was just kind
of going in to do it and then now all of
a sudden the hands are being shown but
let's look at the other side you know
the other side is anytime uh it happens
in sports it happens in families it
happens in companies oh look what's
going on in Amazon six of Jeff Bezos
c-suite Executives all resigns on the
same day you know hey look at the Elon
Musk today with Twitter
1250 employees resigned that place is a
civil war today right and they'll say
things like this and us as readers we're
not in it we're like oh wow shit's
hitting the fan in right you know
Twitter shits in the fan in this place
if you look at it where with a Wagner
group okay Wagner group or whatever they
want to call themselves
um these guys come out and he's a
billionaire himself he's done well for
himself and hey our goal is to do this
and our goal is to do that and then
story comes out saying Putin disappears
after Wagner uh uh cool chaos Daily Mail
Russian president of Vladimir Putin has
not been seen publicly since he
addressed the nation regarding the
Wagner group failed
amidst uh rumors of Putin's flight to
tavare region U.S Secretary and state
Anthony blinken wonderful guy by the way
noted cracks emerging in the Russian
Administration Putin in a pre-recorded
message termed the Wagner troops move as
a staff in the back of our troops around
the people of Russia what we are facing
now is a treason okay and then obviously
talks about who evgeny is and what he's
in all this stuff which I'd love for you
to talk about that as well
when that happens from the outset it's
very easy for the enemy to say look
what's going on over there even his
people don't support his decision he's
about to be replaced it's about to be
very quickly like the last time this
happened we saw this 25 years ago when
this took place within a week somebody
came in and took over Russia that's
exactly what's going to be happening
right uh opposing message of how you
said this thing's going to be done in
Ukraine very quickly the other side said
he's about to fall in the next week
watch this thing's gonna happen very
quickly that's not a good look when that
happens where the leader of a country
has to leave because they're worried
about what's going to happen to him so
one from the optic standpoint two from
he's got an 89 approval rating if he
does why are people going against him
and there's clips of people supporting
evgeny saying hey thank you for doing
this Optics matter
well the people that were thinking uh
you've got any progression were not
thanking him for rising up in some sort
of Uprising they were thanking him and
the Wagner group for their
heroic performance on behalf of the
Russian people
and those same people that were doing
that also said you know we we love Putin
we love our president
I I think people first of all made a
mistake of assuming that what was
happening was an uprising it never was
and pagosian made that very clear
we'll learn more in the future
but what we know at this point is the
following first of all Putin didn't flee
anywhere Putin wasn't afraid of anything
as thirty thousand troops he did take
ten thousand in the ministry of interior
forces these are very very heavily armed
police and moved them into various areas
because they had intelligence already on
many Ukrainian terrorist cells they
simply went out there and eliminated all
of these that was simply a case of let's
go do it get it over with in the event
that there's something going on between
them and this group in in the Wagner
group
it turns out that uh Putin did talk
directly to pragosian that came out
today
assuming that's true he he claimed that
he was talking to lukashenko who's the
president of middle Russia now if that's
in fact true and Putin talked to him
then the whole thing ended very quickly
and the argument for ending it according
to pagosian was we don't want to we'll
want to shed any Russian blood so then
the question is why did you do it
and one of the key reasons I think that
there are two possibilities one is
I think pagosian was speaking for a lot
of people who were very dissatisfied
with karasimov and shoigu because they
feel strongly that this Ukrainian War
should be brought to a close let's stop
it the only way to stop it is to advance
to attack and crush the enemy
and their view is that there's so little
left now on the Ukrainian side why are
we waiting let's get this done the
longer we wait the greater the
possibility that NATO and his friends
will find an excuse to intervene and we
don't want that to happen
Putin's taking the position well I'm
holding back just in case nato
intervenes in other words I've got
hundreds of thousands of troops I've got
a huge strategic Reserve if they're dumb
enough to intervene then I've got that
you know on hand that I can employ
that's a debate that is unfolding we're
hearing about a shake-up in the Russian
high command you'll recall that Putin
had a meeting with some journalists a
small group of them and he talked to
them for three hours something you never
hear anybody in the United States do
any politician that is and he was very
straightforward and Frank we had the
transcripts and one of the things that
came up was a discussion about the
senior leadership
and one of the journalists said you know
we're we're concerned because we're
getting feedback from a lot of soldiers
that we can do better that we need more
aggressive more capable leaders and he
said you know I think there's something
to that and I've got to look into it
I've got to look at it I think we're
going to see a shake up in the high
command now there's a an unsubstantiated
rumor out there that the
commander-in-chief of Russian Airborne
forces is now taking over the theater I
don't know
I haven't seen it confirmed anywhere
that could be the case also in the same
report garazimov is returning to his
essential duties as chief of the general
staff he's no longer going to run
anything in connection with the war in
Ukraine
shoigu seems to be shoigu he's Putin's
friend I don't think Putin holds him
because he's a civilian he's not a
professional Soldier directly
responsible for anything that's not
right
so I think we'll see some shake up in
the high command and that may foreshadow
some offensive action
now here's another theory that this was
a carefully constructed show for the
West
to convince everybody that Russia was
falling apart and see who said what and
so forth I don't buy that yeah I don't
either I buy the first argument yeah and
people say well you know my gosh how
could this happen
George Marshall relieved 32 core and
division commanders during less than
three years of fighting during World War
II uh large numbers of senior officers
were removed and and changed and moved
around and given new commands uh this is
this is not unusual in war it happens if
it doesn't happen you're in a lot of
trouble I mean one of the complaints
that I've had about the U.S military and
the Army in particular is no change
why no change well it's a stagnant pool
of people and talent you need fresh
blood fresh eyes and I'm sure that
Putin has discovered that's required in
the in the Russian military and I think
we'll see it
beyond that I can't speculate anymore
because I don't know and I I haven't
talked to anybody who does you know the
whole thing about you know
uh uh look if we keep going the way
we're going this NATO thing is going to
get done with Ukraine and they're going
to become a member we got to kind of
slow our roll the way we're going look
whether they go hard or go soft what do
you think are the chances that Ukraine's
eventually going to be part of NATO
non-existent non-existent yes that's not
going to happen no and this is the
problem we don't seem to understand it
if we continue to insist that whatever
remains of Ukraine become part of NATO
we're going to see hundreds of thousands
of Russian troops on the Polish border
they're they're just going to roll right
across Ukraine they will not stop until
they hit the Polish border in the
Romanian border that's very clear that's
not what he wants and the re and I keep
trying to explain this to people if you
know anything about Western Ukraine I
grew up with people from Western Ukraine
they do not want anything to do with the
Russians and Putin knows that he doesn't
want to run the place doesn't want to
govern it he just doesn't want it to be
a platform for attack against Russia
which is what we tried to turn it into
I also think the majority of ukrainians
that are still there and maybe even the
majority of their way they may not like
Russians but I don't think they support
this war
and the reason I say that is if you go
back to the election that brought
solenski to power when he was picked up
from nowhere as a comedian and sponsored
by kolamoisky who's a very powerful
oligarch in Ukraine
he ran on a peace platform he said if
I'm elected I'll make peace with Russia
well virtually everybody something
something like 89 percent went out and
voted for it they wanted peace with
Russia there were only a very few people
in the far west of Ukraine that that
didn't support that so I I don't think
uh zielinski is by any stretchy
imagination as widely supported as
people think and you know you talk about
their situation right now he has press
gangs press gangs or groups of people
that go out and forcibly drag ukrainians
into the Ukrainian military because they
need Manpower he's now doing that in the
Far Western portions of Ukraine where he
said he wouldn't do it in Galicia and in
the Carpathian what used to be called
the Carpathian military District
ukrainians are leaving ukrainians are
moving out there are reports now that
ukrainians are actually stoning and in
some cases shooting at these press gangs
from the Ukrainian Army in in Western
Ukraine that they don't want to go to
war they don't want to fight we're
getting reports that platoon and
company-sized elements down in southern
Ukraine are defecting there's simply
saying look we've had it we can't do
this anymore and they're coming across
and surrendering and very very smartly
the Russians from the beginning have
treated all of the Ukrainian prisoners
very very well
they have not harmed them they have not
abused them or brutalized them they
facilitated prisoner exchanges whereas
we've got videotape of Ukrainian
Soldiers kneecapping with with the
AK-47s Russians Russian knees of
soldiers that are in captivity we have
them we have video of them executing
because the Ukrainian soldiers that did
actually posted it
uh on YouTube
on the internet so
he he's run a very good campaign in the
sense that he's made it very clear we
don't want to kill you we're not really
the enemy we want this to end too
and it has had an effect inside Ukraine
that we are not hearing about these
things are not reported to us in the
western media because it undermines the
narrative did you see the Wall Street
Journal story about a few days ago of
Wagner Mutiny revives U.S fears over
control of Russia's nuclear weapons the
Wagner parliamentary party military uh
paramilitary group failed Insurrection
Russia led by evgeny has reignited
concerns over control of Russia's
nuclear Arsenal as U.S Secretary of
State Anthony blinking put it anytime
you have a major country like Russia
that has signs of instability that's
something of concern despite these
tensions U.S officials stated that they
detected no irregular activities or
changes in alert levels related to
Russia's nuclear forces is that a real
threat or is that just a you know story
to over
exaggerate what's really going on to put
fear in the American people absolutely
second one yes absolutely you're not
hearing anything truthful from this
Administration
and the media is conspiring with the
administration to misinform the public
it's simple truth the same thing's
happening in Western Europe nobody is
being told the truth the only way to get
the truth is to talk to people who are
over there on the ground fortunately I
have some people who are willing to do
that and pass me information and we
forget that there are people in Poland
that have grandparents who are
ukrainians living in eastern Ukraine we
forget that there are people who are
Slovakian some are Czech who actually
have brothers-in-law or cousins working
in banks in Moscow
in other words there are people over
there that are telling the truth
I just don't think uh we're getting it
and I don't see any evidence that that's
going to change anytime soon and that
worries me because if we continue to
push this false narrative and we make it
abundantly clear that there will be no
negotiation which is what we're
effectively saying right now Putin has
the following choice you can pull all
your forces out of Ukraine
you can prepare to commit suicide in
public and remove yourself from office
and then we'll talk
I mean that's absurd there's no chance
of any of that happening
so what where are we headed I think
we're headed to lots of Russian troops
on the Polish border unless someone
wakes up in Europe and I think it could
happen in Germany and it could happen in
France where those governments are very
fragile right now I think uh Schultz's
approval rating is about 32 or 33
percent if they get rid of him and you
get a new Coalition involving the
alternative for Germany
and maybe even the left on the far left
those two groups are all opposed to this
war and there is no support in the
German population for going to war with
Russia if you ask anybody in Germany are
you prepared to suit up and go to the
Eastern Front everybody says are you out
of your mind of course not
if that were to happen then Putin would
have someone he could talk to in Berlin
and Berlin then could conceivably lead
us out of this Dead End Road
but that hasn't happened yet and again I
think that's something else that Putin
is watching for I think that's another
reason why he's held back
Russia and Germany grown close over
energy deals and pipelines and there was
this uh wasn't there a story narrative
that they you know thanks to the
Russians turning off the pipeline as
part of the Ukraine conflict these poor
Germans are going to be freezing in the
winter and so aren't they friendly to in
recent times fairly dependent on Russia
and probably you know uh in a position
where it might not be a bad idea to be
the to be the uh you know moderating
voice in 90 right in 1914
Russia and Germany were each other's
principal trading partners
in other words when the war broke out
they were already each other's principal
trading partners interestingly enough
the British were entirely dependent on
the Optics industry in Germany for all
of its military applications well uh I
mean these things happen sometimes dumb
ideas become policy without anybody
Consulting The Wiz on the wisdom of
doing something in 1941
Russia and Germany were each other's
principal trading partners Germany could
not have launched any offensive in the
West in 1940 without copious amounts of
Steel and coal and iron and oil and gas
and so forth from Russia impossible
grain poured into Germany in other words
this is a symbiotic relationship that's
been there for a long time this existed
between Prussia and Russia and the
prussians were always pro-russian as a
result and worked to avoid any conflict
this was bismarck's argument
the austrians were were less open-minded
but they too sort of shut up and colored
because they were in a position to do
much my point is this is a natural
relationship it benefits both sides we
have looked at this and said this is
evil and bad because this makes Germany
dependent upon Russia but we forget that
Russia was also dependent upon Germany
and what happened in 1941 in July that
changed everything it's called Lend
Lease from the United States we
compensated Russia with everything that
it had formally been receiving from
Germany technology Steel
locomotives you name it all the
resources aluminum all the precious
metals everything that the Communists in
Moscow needed to survive the German
assault we started providing immediately
in July 1941 and we were not even part
of the war it was illegal and FDR did
that now I'm not here to debate the
wisdom of that that's another subject
but my point is Russia also is dependent
on Germany just as Germany has been
dependent on Russia so the notion that
it's a one-way street is just inaccurate
and wrong so Colonel worst case best
case worst case scenario here okay best
case obviously we know what the best
case is okay they figured out it's done
you know there's a way to coexist and
everything goes smoothly as though how
bad is the worst case this question has
been asked many people have gone to
different places give different elements
of worst case
here's here's the thing that concerns me
most of all that could lead to the
quote-unquote worst case which I regard
as a nuclear exchange all right
no no one in Russia Putin no one in
Beijing neither government has an
interest in launching a nuclear weapon I
mean they understand that if you use a
nuclear weapon the rapidity with which
war will escalate is mind-numbing
that's that's the the great myth of the
so-called tactical nuclear weapon that
you hear from the U.S Air Force and
others and the Navy oh well we can shoot
a nuke a low yield only five kilotons
only kill maybe 30 or 40 000 people no
one will notice in other words this is a
useful Battlefield weapon outrageous
nonsense it is not if any nuclear weapon
is used
everybody escalates and the reason for
that is simple everyone's afraid that if
they don't use their Arsenal they'll
lose it
so we don't want to get there how do we
get there if we're stupid if we're
stupid
and we try to engage the Russians
conventionally we'll lose
if there's one thing the Russians can
handle it's conventional Warfare you've
already seen that in Ukraine
they can defeat us conventionally we
don't have enough forces to send we
don't have enough troops on active duty
if we try to suddenly mobilize and send
someone across the Atlantic we're going
to encounter a huge Russian submarine
Fleet which will sink everything that
tries to cross the Atlantic
we will have no support out of anyone in
Northeast Asia the Koreans the Japanese
nobody wants to be part of this war so
if you think you're going to have a back
door into Russia across the Pacific
you've lost your mind
so if we engage them in conventional
terms we will lose and we don't want to
do that in other words let's not let's
not push that envelope but that means
that you have to recognize two things
first of all in Europe these borders
have changed dozens of times over a
thousand years
everybody looks at at this border that
constitutes the current Ukrainian
construct that says oh well that could
never change it's absurd it never made
any sense when Lenin created it because
the ukrainians live primarily west of
the Nipper and a little bit to the east
to the very Northern edge of white
Russia that's it and this thing called
Ukraine Ukraine which means on the edge
or the margin or something had been
ruled by the duchy of Lithuania then the
kingdom of Poland and the Polish
Lithuanian Commonwealth for hundreds of
years and ownership passed back and
forth with Russia because the Polish
Lithuanian Commonwealth fell apart
largely on its own
my point is that we we are imputing a
degree of legitimacy to these borders
that was never there and that was
Putin's speech that he gave months ago
long before the war saying look these
borders don't make any sense because
you've got all these Russians in the
East Brzezinski when he was alive
pointed to that and said that's
dangerous we need to sit down and talk
with the Russians and fix this problem
because otherwise the presence of all of
these Russians in eastern Ukraine is
going to end up being a catalyst for war
now we thought we thought we could get
the ukrainians to maintain a
quote-unquote multinational
Multicultural state where these people
would be accepted and could live as
co-equals this is the Minx Accords that
you said yes later people said no we
were lying yeah but the truth is in
Europe how well have multinational
multilingual Multicultural States worked
well not so good you know the Soviet
Union fell apart instantly and what do
you have now multiple Nations
Yugoslavia fell apart very rapidly you
have multiple Nations check go Slovakia
fell apart instantly because checks in
slovaks didn't want to live together
this is the history of Europe
and historically great Powers have come
to terms with each other and said look
let's come up with this compromise it
may not be perfect we may have to
revisit this in 20 years but let's get
peace in other words let's establish
peace first then we can come back and
revisit it in the future as necessary to
ensure everybody's interests are met we
won't do that we have built ourselves up
into this foolish notion that we're the
indispensable superpower
we must dominate everything nothing on
this planet can happen without us wrong
this planet went went on for thousands
of years before we showed up
you know we can go anywhere you want
with the Armenians with the Turks talk
about Azerbaijan I was talking to
somebody and I said you realize these
are azeri Turks and this was a member of
Congress said what's that I mean
Americans don't know anything that
happens beyond their borders frankly we
don't study it and the people that are
governing us aren't paying attention to
it and right now you try to explain
Ukraine and they don't understand what
that is what it really means it's
history if they understood any of it we
wouldn't be involved in it we're not
competent to sort this out the Europeans
need to sort it why though unpack that
so if we did know the history we
wouldn't be involved in it why wouldn't
be we be involved in it because there
has been so much hatred in Bloodshed in
that part of the world over the last
hundred years that it's virtually
impossible for us to go in and reconcile
all of these parties in other words
there to some extent it has to be fought
out and I think that's already largely
happened and if we were smart we would
sit down and recognize that this has
happened and say enough is enough how
much more blood has to be spilled I
don't think we need to spill any more
blood in that region and we need to
redraw the borders we need to make
western Ukraine whatever remains of it
neutral
you remember the whole uh uh two days
before 9 11 Rumsfeld comes out saying
2.3 trillion dollars of Money's been
missing and you know that whole story of
what happened and the 911 took place and
hey you know weapons of mass destruction
we have to do all of that that led to
there was no weapons of mass destruction
and that one video where President Bush
says well you know what what's going on
right now and they're you know trying to
take over Iraq he says oops you know a
similar thing I don't know if you've
seen what he's given that speech so a
lot of people are sitting there saying
okay so who wants this thing to continue
Eisenhower prepped everybody right after
he was done saying be careful with the
whole military industrial complex JFK
was kind of pushing the envelope saying
hey we gotta also go through this Trump
was also saying there's no need to go
into half these worlds what wars why do
we have 780 military bases but who wants
this thing to continue and who benefits
the most is if this thing continues well
remember that the basis that you're
referring to are really a product of the
Cold War and the fact that after to the
second world war ended we were literally
the only man standing Europe was in
ruins the Soviet Union was by no means
strong enough to wage a new war they'd
lost we think now they'd lost during the
war of 39 million
so we we were the only Power Japan was
prostrate we had to stay in Japan
because we had left Japan it could have
become a Soviet satellite in other words
most of the things that we did after
1945 have to do with Communism
containing it suppressing it and
remember the idea was that you don't
confront directly militarily you contain
it until it finally implodes guess what
it worked they imploded we like to say
well we caused it but the truth is the
system itself was so dysfunctional it it
was going to implode on its own totally
get it yeah so then this ends and then
you've got a lot of people in Washington
say well we we hold all the cards
we're the only superpower in other words
we're the British Empire after Waterloo
you know we can intervene everywhere we
can reshape the world in our own image
of this man wolfowitz who wrote a
document in the Pentagon that
essentially says we're going to become
altruistic imperialists we're going to
go over there right the wrongs make make
the world safe for us make it safe for
our lives make it safe for Israel
whatever you know go down the list this
was wolfowitz everybody adopted this and
said this is great because there's no
one who can challenge us remember Desert
Storm Desert Storm sent this message
look we've got things nobody else has
nobody can take us on
now the truth is that everything that we
had in Desert Storm as a monopoly has
been lost and all the Technologies and
capabilities that we had then that no
one else did are now everywhere
everybody's got them and you can see
that happening right now in Ukraine
so the world has changed but we did not
we decided Well you know we're we're
going to run this place and we're going
to structure the financial system the
Global Financial system to suit us we're
going to use it to force people to do
the things we want them to do and we're
doing it all in the name of this
crusading liberal Democratic approach in
other words we're Crusaders for Liberal
democracy
well that doesn't hold up what to close
scrutiny I mean let's face it that's a
lot of nonsense behind the scenes you
have all of these people invested in
personally and in terms of their wealth
invested in This Global structure we
call it security and the rest of the
world looks at it is potentially
dangerous American Military presence
I don't know that Americans realize that
this hangover from the cold war is
primarily responsible for it but if you
have lots of money going into weapon
systems into programs into policies into
foreign aid that have been going there
and going there and going there and
going there you have lots of people on
the hill and you have lots of donors who
control the hill that profit from that
they don't want that to stop and that
was Trump's great uh sin if you will in
Washington he's disrupting the money
flow
if Trump gets away with this we're going
to go broke we'll lose money
that was the reason Trump was hated
despised and successfully subverted I
would add
but we still have to do it we still have
to stop it and we're up against a group
of people in Washington want to keep it
going
now when does this end when you know
what did Ben Stein said it goes on until
it can't
and you know we can debate about the
true structure of the economy the
underlying fundamentals which I don't
think are particularly good I'm there
with ricards and others who think we're
headed for serious trouble
but there are lots of people who say oh
no we can print money in perpetuity and
do whatever we want I think it's going
to end
when it ends what happens historically
is the Empire the overseas possessions
vanish
troops come home the Investments end and
you start over from scratch
and I think that's where we're headed
when it ends will Putin still be the
leader of Russia of course yeah he's
dying of uh terminal cancer remember
right he was supposed to be dead at
least a year or two ago right yeah he'll
probably be around yeah so so so you
what you're saying is if you're saying
when it ends uh uh he's still going to
be the leader of Russia you're saying
it's going to end pretty soon it's not
going to be ending any time you know I I
don't know uh you know the you know the
Black Swan concept I think there's a
pond out there with lots of black swans
swimming around when will one of them
take off you know if I knew that I'd be
a billionaire I'd be as rich as you does
does BlackRock want it to continue does
BlackRock want it to keep going well I
think BlackRock wants to control as much
of Ukraine as it can Monsanto and a
number of other firms are all in there
because you're talking about some of the
richest agricultural land in the world
you know about 15 20 feet of Black Earth
I mean it was so rich that during the
war Hitler tried to load box cars with
it and bring it back to Germany that's
how valuable it is I've had Russians and
ukrainians tell me you know stick
anything you want in the ground it'll
grow something it's that good
so uh I'm sure that there are lots of
people who would like to get at a lot of
people would like to get it Russia's
resources
I mean there's always that aspect in any
War
but will this work I I don't know I mean
I feel badly personally for the
ukrainians because they're the victims
in all of this Tom do you have any
questions on the Ukraine Russia Wagner
before I move on to the next next topic
yeah not not on Wagner it's a very
interesting perspective to see that you
know what it was and and what it wasn't
far uh far as you see and also I think
the history lesson is very instructive
because most Americans don't understand
that Ukraine was the Bread Basket of of
Europe in terms of the amount of wheat
corn
um you know sugar beets and all the
things that we have over here that are
our principal crops I mean
that is is phenomenal and now this is
all being disrupted and there is a big
parlor game going on to see who's going
to win The Spoils of rebuilding it the
way you know Halliburton rebuilt you
know dams and power plants and sewage
treatment plants and big infrastructure
in Iraq
yeah no I think that's right keep this
in mind during World War One 400 000
Germans starved to death in the last two
and a half years of the war because of
the British royal navies blockade
enough food simply could not reach them
and these weren't the soldiers these are
citizens in in The Villages they weren't
the soldiers and in fact I I knew people
when I was an exchange student whose
grandparents had made the decision to
die
so that the rest of the family would
have food I mean that's how bad it was
in Germany and Austria
uh when World War II breaks out what is
Hitler obsess over Ukraine he wants to
get it he wants to control it and hold
it because of its capacity to produce
food
so that tends to distort the whole
strategic approach to the war in Russia
that's how important it is and there's
no doubt that people would like to get
control of it now the point is if it's
going to be a neutral place
I don't know if anybody is going to help
the ukrainians sort through all of this
so that they are not stolen blind but I
guess that could happen
so you you've said where today we have
44 star generals to 44 one star 44 uh no
it's 44 four-star generals today to 1
million total soldiers 1.1 1.1 in World
War II we had ten four-star generals to
16 million soldiers uh let me see now I
got to go back and look at this you had
Eisenhower MacArthur Arnold
and uh MacArthur Arnold Eisenhower and
Marshall
uh so that's four and then you had
Nimitz Leahy and King three that's seven
so at the height of the war
in other words
1943-44 you had seven four stars
in command of a 12.2 Million Man force
now that was not an accident that was by
Design
because Marshall made it very clear that
he did not have time to argue with
people and see as soon as you create
another four star interesting you have
to argue with the four star I'm a four
star you have to listen to me Marshall
didn't want to be bothered
this changes in January of 1945 because
we knew the war was going to end and we
started promoting people not to
positions of greater power and influence
but as honorifics in other words we make
Bradley a four-star thank you for coming
kind of thing we picked other people and
made them four stars and then of course
the men that I just mentioned to you
became five stars the seven yeah yeah
most of them became five stars because
they had done such wonderful things I I
don't know that Leahy did I think he may
have retired as a four-star but the
bottom line is
there was an understanding that you had
to have Unity of effort there is no
Unity of effort unless you have unity of
command there must be someone in command
in charge at every level
in other words who is in charge remember
there's this wonderful scene in
Kubrick's movie about uh Apocalypse Now
and uh I think Martin Sheen walks up as
a captain and says to a soldier who's
who's in command here
I thought you were
in other words everything's falling
apart because nobody knows who's in
charge so Marshall was absolutely hard
over to prevent that from happening and
I think King had a similar attitude
so that you he didn't want to have to
fight with other Navy four stars over
the disposition of resources the
allocation of landing craft the
allocation of Oilers and tankers the
allocation of carriers at submarines and
so forth
so but but the point with that from
there to today
1.1 million today to say 12.2 million in
44 right
okay how many how many the 12.2 million
were drafted how many of the 12.2
million didn't volunteer they were just
kind of you have to go out there and do
it do you know the number on what the
12.2 was it two-thirds I would I would I
would surmise at least two-thirds okay
let's just say let's just say two-thirds
so let's just say 8 million of the 12
million were drafted 4 million were
there so
that's dad what does that stat say about
us today does it mean this is how I read
it and then correct me and challenge me
and say no that's not what that means so
the way I see it is are four-star
generals today turning into politicians
are they more politicians than their
military leaders and two
do I feel safer with the military we
have today of 1.1 million where you're
looking at the advancement other
countries are making investments into uh
say a China say A you know any of our
enemies that we have they're making
investments into things where you're
reading about you know for longest time
people would say well there's a pandemic
coming there's a pandemic and Bill Gates
2015 whatever the speech was a pandemic
one day is going to come a pandemic one
day is going to work ah yeah whatever
I'm gonna go back to my business I'm
going to watch the Laker again I'm going
to go back you know go back to my job
now they're talking about well you know
what are you going to do when the
banking system collapses come on man
what are you talking about let's go back
to playing a video game on fortnite now
what are you going to do when they do a
Cyber attack on you and this is what's
gonna what are you gonna do when they
attack you from this one okay so are we
safer today more experienced today with
a stronger military to defend our
enemies or were we more capable of
defending our country and defending our
freedom 30 years ago than we are today
well 30 30 40 50 60 70 80 years ago the
military establishment understood that
its preeminent mission was to defend the
United States and the American people
uh does engaging in an intervention in
eastern Ukraine against Russia
constitute defending the United States
and the American people I would argue it
doesn't
does removing Qaddafi in charge of Libya
who had effectively agreed to do
everything we asked of him does that
constitute an act of defense of the
United States I would say no
I I don't think we've been defending
anything for a long time and indeed we
don't even defend our borders
for a hundred years from roughly 19 1848
49 until 1948.
the United States Army secured and
guarded the border with Mexico it also
secured and guarded most of the border
with Canada
we had dozens of Cavalry regiments and
that was their whole mission in life
every general of the second world war
Eisenhower patent-pershing everybody
they had all served on the Mexican
border that was considered a
strategically vital Mission all right
suddenly there's nobody there
the borders are open what's wrong with
this picture we no longer need to secure
our borders
so I I would argue that we got a real
problem because right now where's the
money go it goes into exotic things
designed to sustain us overseas
most of our investment goes into things
that we want to use to intervene in the
internal affairs of other countries the
first principle of our foreign policy is
enunciated by Washington and was
followed really up until the time of
McKinley when he decided to go into the
Spanish-American war was
non-interference in other people's
Affairs our our goal was to stay out of
Wars wars were destructive they were
losers bad for business we didn't want
anything to do with them so that's the
first thing second thing is
these 44 four stars
imagine trying to get anything done how
many of these people are in the regional
unified commands how many of these
people are in functional commands in
other words you've got a strategic
command you've got trans Transportation
command then you've got Central Command
which we and then you have what used to
be pacific command we've now extended
that and called it indo-pacific command
uh really what what are we doing in the
Indian Ocean I mean what's our what's
our goal are we interested in colonizing
India for God's sakes I mean this is
absurd I remember when Africa command
was was created
and I was still on active duty and I
said to the man one of the men who was
going over there I said has anybody
considered the possibility that large
numbers of Africans are offended by the
fact that we have established a military
command called Africa command how would
we respond if the Chinese the Russians
stood stood up a headquarters with
four-star general in command and other
you know dozen other generals it's
called America command why do you need
America command well we're going to
attack America why do you need Africa
command well we want to intervene in
Africa effectively attack it yeah Yep
this kind of thing is is crazy
so all of these people are sort of minor
satreps in other words it's a minor
amirs if you will and you can't run the
show you can't get anything done that
makes any sense and each of them has an
interest in building up his or her
fiefdom in other words they have to
exaggerate their importance to American
National Security
you know so the man who's got south Com
Southern command who deals with the
Caribbean and Latin America uh he needs
X number of resources the person over
here in Africa needs X number of
resources the persons in European
command and so forth do we really need
all of these commands well you live in a
world today with instantaneous
satellite-based Communications
the reason if you look at army posts in
the west that you have an Army Post in
Fort Leavenworth and then you have an
Army Post at Fort Riley and then you had
another Army Post in Western Kansas it
was one day ride on a horse from post to
post that was the logic and the
rationale for where we built posts
Communications what do we need all these
commands for we don't
we know we are not living in the in the
mid 20th century it's over we live in a
very different world today and how much
does it benefit us As Americans to
intervene in the internal affairs of
others I would argue what 7 trillion
lost in the Middle East between
Afghanistan and Iraq that doesn't even
begin to address the damage we've done
to our own citizens that served in
uniform that uh the medical care for
decades is this a benefit to us and
where did all of this money come from
well I guess we know where that was the
answer to that it came off the printing
press
we borrowed it
we need a lot of printing presses for
this though yeah when you're looking at
the budget here for National Defense
it's give or take some will run 840 850
billion dollars okay
who determines where this money goes to
like if we were to say you know we're
gonna buy this we're going to buy this
we're going to buy this we need to
invest into this who's in the room that
decides here's what we need to invest
into to be ready for future Wars that
could take place 5 10 15 years from now
not the wars that we fought 10 20 years
ago who makes that decision well you're
you're asking a question of who there is
no one person that makes those decisions
you have lots of different people from
the various armed services and commands
as well as the federal agencies that
support them that have input to that
decision in other words they have wish
lists they have recommendations and then
you have the Congress and remember the
Congress has a very different incentive
structure when you go to the House of
Representatives of the Senate uh if you
if you turn to Mitch McConnell and say
you know Mitch we don't think we really
need
Fort Campbell Kentucky
you know Fort Campbell Kentucky we don't
need to be there we can move those
forces elsewhere they would be more
readily Deployable and readily I'm
offended I was at the hunter for
cerebral that that would offend me yeah
but you but you understand you say that
and the whole Kentucky delegation will
throw itself in front of that on rushing
train well the building knows that the
generals in the Army know that they they
want to keep that 101st which in my
judgment is increasingly an
anachronistic organization if you look
at what's happening in Ukraine what
happens to all the helicopters
so what are we doing with this thing you
could say the same thing about the 82nd
I mean there's a wonderful wonderful
book that's called when when failure
thrives
it's all about the failure of Airborne
operations for the last 60 70 years so
if that's true do we need 15 000
paratroopers
you know they'll we haven't even begun
to address the Marine Corps and the
Marines are fighting within themselves
right now over what they think they
should be doing
well has anybody decided what the
mission for Marines ought to be who is
actually in charge on the civilian side
so the the people on the hill they love
these headquarters oh you're you're
sending a four-star to Tuscaloosa
nowhere Alabama oh we love that how much
money are you going to spend for the
building that the four star is going to
occupy and how many jobs are you
bringing in this is crazy but this is a
result of the Cold War because the cold
war created the appetite and the
opportunity our budget was three billion
dollars in 1944 I just looked it up
right now so three billion dollars seven
four-star generals let's just say less
than 10 four-star generals they're
sitting there they're talking what to do
with this you know I wonder in the
following way where
the last time we had a president that
served in the military was what who was
it President Bush it was senior right is
this senior is the last one so that's
that's 30 years that's a long time ago
since we had a president that served in
in a in a military W is just the
reserves W was just reserves right but
but when when you think about this
um how does like what I would want and I
don't know if you have the answer to
this question how does how does China
decide where they invest into their
military how does Russia decide where to
invest into the military if we were to
pull up our top five biggest enemies
how did they make the decision on where
the money is being invested in are they
unified in the decisions that's being
made there versus in America
it's political what the Investments are
being made I mean we're living in an era
right now which I don't know if you
agree with this or not according to you
know some of our guys whether you want
to talk about Kirby whether you want to
talk about you know many of the generals
we have today the super soldier today is
part of the lgbtq community you know
today's uh super soldier is is has got
to be a trans because you know we're
we're learning I mean that's the way to
go right and the imagine the amount of
innovation and research we've done to
realize that the best soldiers are them
but I want to know how my enemy
decides the budget do they sit in a room
and they're fully unified do they sit in
a room and they say hey how about we
make that company BlackRock all this
money how about we get this contract to
Raytheon north of Grumman how about we
get these guys that 30 years ago we had
50 different companies that we bought
military equipment from now they bought
each other there's only five of them
left today
you know why don't we we need that guy's
money for campaign distribution what
that's the part I have a concern with
because if we're gonna make these
Investments like this that's going to
benefit a company out there well we're
not really protecting this country we're
just figuring out a way to get reelected
and get more campaign donations oh
listen now you've broken the code
there's no question about it and it's
it's useful to just pause for a second
and talk about the Chinese dilemma
people are imputing all sorts of things
to China right now they they are
magically uh shipping all the fentanyl
to the United States no they're selling
fentanyl to the drug cartels and it's
not the government it's organized crime
in China actually that's involved in
this and the organized crime problem in
China is enormous
there are 1.4 billion Chinese
and every morning she does not wake up
and think about how he can defeat the
United States he wakes up and wonders
how he can stay in power
how he can manage this chaotic mess how
he can hold it together I mean he just
destroyed the shadow banking industry in
China That's beginning to have a
terrible effect on the economy
because Shadow banking was the source of
many of the loans that were necessary to
sustain growth they got a growth problem
in China they have a huge corruption
problem in China a few months a few
years ago they arrested and then
ultimately executed as I understand it
the man who's responsible for
shipbuilding because he was deliberately
overseeing the building of faulty holes
in the pla Navy
you know everybody says well this is a
300 ship Navy and China has outstripped
us 100 of those vessels are Coast Guard
vessels nobody ever brings that up
nobody ever brings up the fact that
Chinese really don't like to go to Sea
they don't want to be out there it's not
a seafaring Nation
they have just started a submarine Fleet
that is nuclear and nuclear capable
well we've been doing that since the
1950s it takes decades to build a force
like that to train the people to
organize them and equip them effectively
China has huge problems just holding
itself together
so I think we should set China aside and
understand that it is not this
Juggernaut that is Led in one particular
direction
I would see it as a nation that has to
feed itself defeat itself it has to have
Commerce to have Commerce a lot of that
has to go over land or oversea those
things are real but that doesn't mean
that it's a juggernaut bent on war with
anybody
now let's turn to Russia which is a a
smaller entity and it's easier to
understand I think
pujin was responsible for tearing apart
reducing and trying to modernize the old
Soviet military structure the old Soviet
military structure was enormous you know
they had over a million men under arms
at just the Soviet Army they had vast
stores of equipment most of the stuff
had long since become obsolete this is
the problem when you try to modernize a
large Force you can't do it without
facing the very high probability that 10
years after you've modernized it it's
hopelessly Obsolete and you have no
savings with which to do anything else
so he tried to make it smaller and he
succeeded he made it much more he tried
to professionalize it he tried to stop
the brutality inside the old army
barracks which was so characteristic not
just to the Soviet military but also the
Zara stormies
he had some success then it turns out
that he had to use it
and it was too small for the purpose
that he decided to use it for so now
it's up to 750 000 there's a plan to
make it 1.2 million
congratulations President Biden
congratulations NATO you just created
the very thing that you said you were
setting out to stop
did you understand
uh and so in in Russia one man at the
top with the defense minister has
enormous power
he has much more power than Biden much
more power than almost anybody else who
sits in that position to allocate
resources to establish factories to
disestablish factories to build new
formations to disestablish Old
formations
think of Putin not as Stalin but as a
czar
he is roughly as powerful today as the
Czar of Russia was before World War one
that's the kind of power and influence
he wields
and I'm sure he's under a lot of
criticism right now because there are
always people in Russia that say we need
a bigger Force we need a bigger Force
they border how many countries how many
thousands of miles across is the place
I mean you know it's it's
legitimate but he he tried very hard to
economize now he's stuck with the
requirement to maintain a much larger
more lethal military force and you
wonder how how long until you know the
whole thing about 40 Laws of Power I
don't know if you've read 40 Laws of
Power Robert Greene rule number one
never outshine the master there's always
somebody that's looking for you to false
it it can kind of take over your
position you're sitting there saying
these guys are probably even in the mob
it happens all the time where you know
Paul Castellano is the boss and then
John Gotti and Sammy Debo hey y'all kind
of want to take the throne and then John
becomes the boss and then hey is Sammy
going to want to do the same thing I did
to Paul there may be a little bit of
that paranoia in him as well for how
long can I really keep this thing
together people are now Rich they not
have money more than they've ever had
before people were not this Rich they
are richer than ever before so those are
certain concerns and fears that they
have but you know what you made me think
about
you made me think about that the number
one person maybe I may be wrong Rob if
you want to pull up this article if we
were to say who is the number one person
that wants the war to continue could be
zelinski because zelinski just recently
said
that uh there would be no elections
until the war is over with and by the
way this was verified by Snopes if you
want to go to Snopes I know some of our
friends are watching it's called the way
to the bottom it says true so he
probably doesn't want the War I mean you
got a monopoly if the war continues he's
going to be able to stay in power for as
long as possible and maybe his you know
he's already had Ben Stiller that came
and visited him he's at Sean Penn I
believe that spent some time with him
who knows at this pace he may get De
Niro he may get pachino he may get a lot
of different Hollywood celebrities show
up and nicer documentaries I think the
sweaters are becoming higher quality
sweaters you know they're maybe maybe a
sponsorship by you know uh Saks Fifth I
don't know maybe Balenciaga some of
these guys can do stuff with him but he
also probably doesn't want the war to
stop I know it's a very strange paranoid
way of looking at it but there are many
situations like that where when there's
controversy even here sometimes when a
war is going on we kind of typically
tend to re-elect the same person because
we're worried about the mess that's
going on do you think there's an element
of him
wanting the war to continue
the population of Ukraine at the
beginning of this war was 30.5 Million
at least officially that's what they
said if you go back into the 90s it was
well over 50 million
Ukraine has been losing population for a
long time because it's a failed State
it's a terribly corrupt and
dysfunctional society that was true long
before zielinski showed up
the war has made matters worse so now
you're down to we think between 18 and
20 million people still living in
Ukraine wait from 30 and a half million
to can you can you vary 34.5 million so
that's smaller in California now can you
look this up Rob that that's a that's an
in okay so I see the 50 million that
that I totally see the population from
45 in 2013.
to 44 in 2020 to 41 where's the state
the cameras hiding itself so can you
come up a little bit swarov so I can see
it go okay 20 22 38 just under the 38
line that so what is can you Google
Ukraine population today
oh my God if that's the case well I
don't know that they're that their data
has caught up with reality these are the
numbers that are coming out of Europe
well it's 21 to two years from now so
you're saying that if that can be
verified I don't think it was that high
in in 2021 I think that's an
exaggeration because ukrainians have
been leaving forever I mean you know I
go I'm sure you travel I've been on
business in London and Vienna sure and
inevitably I end up talking to someone
who's Ukrainian
and they speak perfect English they're
well educated and I say well good Lord
what are you doing here in London and
they always say well I can't make a
living in Ukraine I can't survive there
you know you've got to become part of
some mob boss's structure if you want to
get anywhere I don't want to do that and
then of course I've said well why don't
you come to the United States and they
say I can't get in you know I say so
you're a Ukrainian you're well educated
you speak English you're obviously smart
and we can't get you in
and you know we ran this stupid thing
called a lottery for years every month
two two people's names were pulled out
in a European Capital it's just
ridiculous you know we could have had
this guy in the United States where he
could have been very productive that's
another story but my point is I don't
think that that original number of 41 is
is accurate at all I think there were
several million who had already left
because they saw no future for
themselves remember this also counts
ukrainians citizens who are overseas
they they include them but they're gone
they're never going to go back in
Germany whereas this is also the expat
Workforce so this really isn't
representing
no and I've Got Friends in Germany right
now are telling me and they've got
ukrainians arriving by the train load
every day and they've told me that in
their conversations with Ukraine's every
single person says I will never go back
by the way I found this article Rob if
you want to pull this up because this is
uh uh uh can you pull up this article I
just sent you what it shows so 1990 it
says it was 51 million
then a few months ago it says it was 36
million and then if you pull up this
article this says uh I don't know what
this organization is t-a-s-s uh pull up
that article right there and go up a
little bit according to a think tank
zoom in according to a think tank since
the start of hostilities in Ukraine last
February
8.6 million people have left the country
and have not returned I would say that's
wrong uh what I'm getting from my
European sources in Poland and Germany
is that it's over 12 million
and climbing every day and I think Tas
is kind of Russian writers controlled by
the government is that correct oh I
would assume so
well got it so this is a this is a
Russian site as well
okay got it well I mean if if these
numbers are accurate people are leaving
you also saw the article that came out
that people from Russia were also
leaving how much how much has a Russian
population lost the last 12 months I
think they lost a few hundred thousand
that that left as soon as it became
clear there was going to be a war
and frankly a lot of the Russians that
uh have said when they've been asked
about good let's get them out of here
they don't really want to be Russians
anyway to hold them that's more their
mindset yeah interesting Russian sees
historic population but remember that at
least at least two million Russians who
were in Ukraine have moved to Russia
can you go a little lower uh Rob I don't
know where you just went you were good
where you were at
Rob what'd you do you just did some
magic there buddy
you went okay there you go
Russia is a stroke population drop
spearing demographic crisis amid war in
Ukraine Russia to Russia to need up to 1
million immigrants a year for eight
years to maintain current population
levels go a little lower to see what
else the article says keep going lower
not the video keep going lower
uh but Western defense officials have
estimated that as many as 250 000
Russian soldiers have been dead in
Ukraine it was at one million so
particularly Putin yeah but this is this
is BS it's just not true these are
fabricated numbers
that they're just not true the Russians
haven't taken those kinds of losses and
I mean I confront this over this is Fox
News saying this so yeah well they're
all part of it they're all singing the
same to me these narratives are cooked
up in London by MI6 and in Langley by
the CIA why would they lie about these
stats I I trust me I'm the same person
that doesn't trust they're trying to get
you to believe that Ukraine is winning
Ukraine has never been winning Ukraine
cannot win that's why Orban the
president of Hungary came out just
recently in the last 20 verses it's no
chance for the Ukraine's to win at all
anybody's on the ground over there knows
the truth they're finished the Russians
haven't lost that that kind of numbers
they've lost maybe 40 000 dead maybe
Colonel normally you know you'll say
people are 50 50 on this I don't even
know if people are 50 50. listen to Mark
Levin give a uh emotional speech about
this himself about how he feels about
Putin I don't know if you've seen this
one or not or where he's at I think this
is an argument where 80 percent of the
population I may be wrong the number may
be closer to 70 percent 80 percent of
population is closer defending Ukraine
and they see Russia as the bully in
America it's very easy to make people
think that because as I said from the
very beginning The Hangover from the
Cold War
and remember that the population in New
York City of which Mr Levin has won is
very much in favor of everything from
open borders to endless war with Russia
to permanent war in the Middle East
against whom ever so I mean I I don't
take anything that comes out of New York
City very seriously well let's let's
transition into the I got three more
topics before we wrap up so the the
consequences of the of what's happening
with woke in the military I was in the
military and when I was in the Army
hunter first Airborne there was gays
there were lesbians and we knew about it
we went out we went to Nashville we'd
party and we'd find out God disguised
this she's this he's both she's both
okay
but it wasn't like hey you know let's
advertise it as you're a hero and you're
this it was just that's kind of where
you were at right versus today now when
you hear what you're talking about the
don't ask don't tell right the don't ask
don't tell yes I'm I'm from the don't
ask don't tell era today it's the hero
making machine lgbtq era it's a
different era we're part of today
um John Kirby rejects bogus claims of
woke policies dragging down Army
Recruitment there is no wokeness in the
military this is what he said right and
army secretary concerned woke military
criticism could hurt the service right
this is recently this article just came
out I'll read this entire article to you
on what's going on where some are saying
well the reason why recruitment is low
is because of all the woke agenda and
all the woke ideology no that's not the
reason why people are not joining the
Army you know Army uh uh secretary
Christine warm warm out expresses
concern about the negative impact of
accusations of awoke military on
recruiting efforts stating I hope that
we do not see more of any of the kind of
talk that's been out there in the past
few days while Republican lawmakers and
pundits criticize the military efforts
towards diversity and inclusion warmouth
clarifies that the Army is focused on
being a ready Army not a woke Army she
emphasizes that concerns about a woke
military have not been a major challenge
in recruiting according to market
research and a defense department survey
warm out acknowledges that some Young
Americans
may be reluctant to join the Army due to
the perception of its being woke but
highlights the importance of countering
the negative rhetoric as it can have
counterproductive effects on recruiting
she emphasizes the influence of news and
social media on Young Americans
perception so is the Army and the
military getting more woke and is it
negatively impact on recruiting
this kind of reminds me of a
non-commissioned officer many years ago
who told me
you know and I think at the time I was a
captain you know Captain uh I've never
had intimate relations with anybody but
an attractive woman
but I have changed my standards on
occasion
my point is
I think Christine well too many drinks
at night at 2 A.M okay I think Christine
vormoud is living in fantasy world
I think that if you're a average 18 19
20 year old man single guy who's even
remotely athletic who wants to be tested
wants to accomplish something in life
wants to join a and a lead organization
and he looks at what's presented to him
in these commercials and what he sees
uh he says thank you but no thank you
I'll go somewhere else
I mean as soon as we started telling
everybody and this started by the time
you know even in the 90s and we saw it
begin in the 70s frankly this is a long
process of what I call rot
uh if you say that little Susie over
there who weighs 90 pounds or 110 pounds
is just as good as Bob who's six feet
tall and weighs 220.
and she can do everything he can do and
there's no difference
good you're going to get a lot of susies
but you're not going to get the other
guy
uh saying that well there's no reason
why they can't be in combat I had an
exchange with a senator when I testified
before the Senate armed services
committee AirLand subcommittee and he
said well Karma Brenner I don't hear you
mention women on the battlefield very
much are you you opposed to to women in
combat
I said yes sir
he said well why is that I said five
thousand years of recorded military
history
you can imagine that didn't go over very
well
uh you you can you can force whatever
you want on federal forces you can
but the people that are going to show up
and fight effectively for you will not
stay they'll leave
I can guarantee it that's true for the
Marine Corps it's true in the Army I
can't speak for the Navy and the Air
Force although I saw recent comments
from this man General Brown CQ Brown
who's supposed to be the next chairman
who is talking about too many white
people too many white Pilots we need
more non-whites and so forth I'm sure
that that will have a deleterious impact
on the Air Force
but maybe it's not as noticeable years
years ago I I had to put together a
study I was on active duty to look at
the impact of various experiences and
and problems in militaries and I came
across the French army
between the years of 1850 and 1871 and
everyone thought
in 1870 when the French army met the
prussians and their allies that the
French army would effectively annihilate
the prussians Russians had almost no
serious combat experience in their
judgment they'd only fought a six-week
war against the austrians that that
wasn't serious in their interview in the
French State fought Mexican state fought
berbers they fought the Russians and the
Crimea and they they were going to be
very effective and so forth and what
happened was the exact opposite the
prussians utterly annihilated them
the point is that the rot that
undermines discipline leadership
uh capability can go on for years
without notice until suddenly you're
thrown into the buzzsaw and you have to
fight then everything that was
previously unidentified or concealed
comes to the fore
IGN that happened to the British in 1914
it happened to them again in 1940. you
you have to look carefully at these
social programs and policies and the
standards of discipline and if they're
not high enough and they don't work you
can't brush them aside you may get by if
you're just going to occupy a forward
operating base and you're fighting an
enemy that has almost no capability and
let's face it the people we faced in
Afghanistan and Iraq had very little
capability they might be able to get off
an occasional mortar or rocket but most
cases they had to depend on remotely
detonated Minds what we call IEDs and
they had AK-47s and RPGs and you know
frankly we had everything we had
absolutely devastating artillery
devastating air power so there was never
any question as to who was going to
dominate and who was going to win you
had frankly something similar in Vietnam
we always had overwhelming Firepower
that could come in and crush the
opponent he just couldn't play put it
together rapidly enough and effectively
enough well those days are over
and if we are going to fight someone
like the Russians
or the Chinese or any of these other
other countries we have to come to terms
with reality that they do not
Implement woke programs they're not
interested in that they're not
interested in making people feel good
they're interested in forces that can
fight
soldiers exist to do one thing to fight
and kill the enemy that's it now they
can do a lot of other things but that's
the preeminent purpose of the whole
structure
we've lost sight of that we lost sight
of it a long time ago yeah you know when
you when you when you think about that
and you see a speech that Putin gives
and he says the West you know America
it's trying to get their military to be
woke he doesn't he uses it in his own
words
and he says we're not compromising our
values and principles here's what we're
all about we're about defending you know
Russia and you see the Applause it gets
from the audience there's thousands of
people out there by the way when is the
last time we got a message like that
from our current president defending
America what a great nation it is and
what it stands for our values and
principles
that you can take the same exact message
Putin gave and Biden's done this a few
times before where he takes messages
from other people around the world and
he uses that his writers can literally
take that put it in Jazzy BT and say
change it up a little bit to make it
sound like Joe Biden put it on the
teleprompter if he gave that message you
know what the American people would do
they would lose their mind they would
they would Applause oh my God who is
this guy
but we we are not given the pro-america
message we are given the pro let's
confuse the hell out of everybody
message where nobody knows who's a hero
today were we once you didn't know what
a hero was today we don't know what a
hero is but I want to play this
recording for you of um
president Trump that just came out and
I'm sure you've seen it and there's a
response from the president from the
president as well if you want to play
this this is what everybody's CNN
everyone's playing saying this is it
it's the end of it after this he
shouldn't be qualified to run if you
want to go ahead and play this and then
we'll show his response sick people but
that was your cue you know against you
well it started right at the time when
Millie's talking about oh you were going
to try to do a kick now they were trying
to do that before you even were sworn in
that's right trying to overthrow your
life well with Millie uh let me see that
I'll show you an example he said
that I wanted to attack Iran
isn't it amazing to have a big pile of
papers this thing just came up look
this was him
they presented me this is off the Record
but they presented me this this was him
this was the defense department in him
we looked at something this was him this
wasn't done by me this was him all sorts
of stuff
keep keep playing it keep playing it
let's see here
yeah I just found isn't that amazing
this totally wins my case you know
except it is like highly contentious
there's a secret information look at
this you attack and Hillary would print
that out all the time
I should send it to Anthony Weiner
by the way isn't that incredible yeah I
was just saying because we're talking
about it and you know he said he wanted
to attack Iran and what he said
this was done by the military given to
me
um I think we can probably get it I
don't know what we'll have to see yeah
we'll have to try to figure out see as
president I could have did last year no
I can't you know but this is yeah I'm so
happy I have a problem is that
interesting yeah it's so cool I mean
it's so I'm look we here and I haven't
can you pause this Rob so who's
recording this uh according to CNN the
audio recording comes from a July 2021
interview Trump gave at his bed Minister
Resort for people working uh on a memoir
for Mark Meadows Trump's former Chief of
Staff okay so go to his who's that lady
who is that lady is that one of his
staffers uh it says here in the article
that the people present a writer
publisher and two of Trump's staff
members two of trump staff members okay
so now go to Trump's response on what he
says about this on uh truth social uh uh
uh you know so the deranged specials
process special prosecutor Jackson in
conjunction with the doj and FBI
illegally leaked and spun a tape and
transcript of me which is actually an
exoneration rather than what they would
have you believe the this continuing
Witch Hunt is another election
interference scam they are cheaters and
Thug so when you see this recording and
you see
you know him talking about Millie and
and you know where he's at and Hillary
and all this other stuff how do you
process this when you see this recording
that uh the media is using to make sure
he can no longer compete for 2024.
well the first thing that I I think uh
is that
president Trump is not unlike most of
his predecessors in that many of the
papers that they took with them when
they left office were not necessarily
carefully uh vetted registered
Declassified whatever
uh I I think we've over the years become
very relaxed in that area secondly I
think we classify too much
that's certainly true
and it's unfortunate uh that that
they're trying very very hard to uh pin
pin some sort of criminal action on him
which is of course absurd now
his point is effectively true
the million others came across along
with Bolton and as I recollect uh the
the former
Secretary of State who was was Pompeo
who said he wanted to run for president
and bowed out
they were all advocates for war with
Iran and you have to look at at least
with Bolton and Pompeo who their quote
unquote donors are where their money
comes from
they wanted war with Iran Millie I'm not
sure he was a strong advocate for it I
have no idea but he certainly wasn't
going to stand in the way we know that
Mackenzie who is down in U.S Central
Command he
apparently his fingerprints are all over
this Global Hawk on unmanned aerial
vehicle that was shot down it was it was
plotted to follow the edge of the air
defense identification Zone which under
international law says that any military
aircraft that violates that zone is
liable to be shot down unless it
identifies itself explains its position
and so forth of course we didn't do that
so in a court of law the Iranians of
international law would have won the
case
at the time no one could say what
happens if we go to war with Iran the
idea was we got to go to war with Iran
it was similar to the wolfowitz Rumsfeld
Shaney cabal that took us into Iraq the
the purpose is to get us into Iraq then
we'll figure it out
very similar to things that were said in
1965 and 66 about Vietnam well what are
we going to do there how well we've got
to get in there let's get in there we'll
sort through that we'll quote unquote
muddle through you never muddle through
you have to know what the purpose is you
have to know how you're going to achieve
that purpose and then you have to have a
vision for what you want it to look like
at the end we call that purpose method
end state
Donald Trump as president of the United
States prevented war with Iran because
he asked first of all
what happens after we launch all of
these strikes
what happens now he said at the time I
was concerned about the loss of human
life in Iran which is legitimate
especially since we did not lose any
human life what we did is we lost an
unmanned aerial vehicle which he did not
think Rose to the threshold that
justified war with Iran and of course he
was right
but it was also a question of okay we
launched all these strikes then what
and you have a lot of people in
Washington that just want to start
something and then convince themselves
they can drag Us in and that somehow or
another the military will make it work
that happened to us in Vietnam it
happened to us in Iraq it happened to us
in Afghanistan it happened to us in
Libya it's happening right now in an
attempt to bring us into some sort of
confrontation with the Russians over
Ukraine
and there are no Syria there's no
serious thinking about what are the
implications what Iran is an enormous
country it's almost the size of Western
Europe it has a large population let's
assume that you can destroy Iran all
right let's just assume you can destroy
it with enough weapons they can't stand
up to us with their air defense networks
or anything else okay so let's assume
you're right we destroy them what do
these people do well they leave
they begin to pour into surrounding
countries because there's nothing for
them to eat there's no water to drink
if you destroy Iran what's the impact
strategically on the region is there
anybody there who benefits from it well
a lot of people seem to think the Turks
would Mr erdogan would then emerge as
the preeminent power in the region
because Iran's really his principle ribs
thing yeah so why would you do that
does that make sense
doesn't make a lot of sense these are
the discussions the British and American
General staffs behind the scenes had
during World War II you want us to
destroy Germany then what
who supplants Germany the Soviet Union
is that our goal do you understand what
I'm saying I'm following Trump did a
good thing he said no I'm not going to
do this I'm not going to support it
and of course you know donors everywhere
were very unhappy because they donated
prolifically to that Administration in
the hopes of bringing on a war with Iran
remember I think it was poderets who
said every morning I get up and prayed
that we go to war with Iran and he was
advising John McCain and McCain was an
advocate for going to war with Iran
McCain was in Kiev saying we'll we'll
fight the Russians we'll stand by you
this is before he passed away
I mean this is lunacy what is happening
who is in charge the American people
don't know what war means I've seen a
country devastated by war I've seen more
than one
they don't understand that we are no
longer in a position of Splendid
isolation where we can destroy other
people's homes without risking the same
here when you start dealing with the
Russians and the Chinese all sorts of
potentially bad things can happen if you
think Mexico is our friend I have news
for you the Mexicans have always sided
with whomever was against the United
States so is Venezuela and so is Cuba
now you really want to go to war with
these people and then have a second
front in the Caribbean in Latin America
do you want to be dragged into that no
one is thinking there is no strategic
thought and no one is thinking about the
American people what's in the interest
of the American people you know what's
in the interest of the American people
build prosperity recover this economy
repatriate jobs get control of the
Border stop the influx of Labor that we
can't employ and if we believe the AI
Fanatics who are telling us that by what
19 what is it 1904 or what is it 2040 or
something
80 percent of all the current
low-skilled jobs will be replaced by AI
what are we bringing most of these
people in to do it's insane doesn't make
any sense
so who's thinking about the United
States American society
nobody do you think this can be used to
eliminate him as a as a candidate or it
still doesn't do anything like they're
they're using everything possible to
eliminate him do you think you know
yesterday I tweeted something Rob if he
can go to Twitter this is just something
I I tweeted yesterday and it got some
people that were uh some were upset some
were curious and some were like you know
why the hell would you even put this out
there so go in and zoom in right there
that one right there if you can make it
bigger okay 2024 strategy to have
Newsome replace Biden okay step number
one have Newsom go around defending
Biden selling Biden's record shows
loyalty step number two have him
constantly attack DeSantis Dems are
convinced Trump will be forced to drop
out step number three if Biden doesn't
step down have mainstream media attack
him it's already happened in ABC CBS NBC
all went after him starting this week
step number four Once Jill Jill Biden
notices these endless attacks have a
private meeting with Biden sharing
strategy to save face if he steps down
step number one multiple documentaries
shown him as a modern day FDR number two
massive Simon and Schuster book deal
three Defenders Legacy and be pardoned
by Newsom if hits the fan next one
choose one of few options to step down
number one due to help number two Jill
and I prayed about it and decided it's
time for us to go spend time with our
grandkids number three we fix everything
Trump broke and now it's time for
someone else to do number four edify
Newsome as being loyal to Biden unlike
the sentence not being loyal to Trump so
then in order to prevent Kamala from
backstab and let her become the first
female president for Split Second
when Biden steps down Hillary will lose
her mind but what's new and number seven
divide the scientists and Trump Camp to
make sure Mega doesn't vote for DeSantis
step number eight that says Newsom
becomes 47 but I should have said 48.
and last but not least it's very likely
none of the above will happen which is
why it's called a prediction but only
the paranoids survive so do you think
like you know do you think Trump's going
to be there next year as a republican
candidate
well first of all only the paranoid
survive is one of the best books I've
ever read Andy Grove he recommended it
to me and if you want to understand
what's wrong with the military
establishment all you have to do is read
what he describes in there with IBM and
all these other major corporations so
it's a brilliant book I I try to get
everybody to read it now secondly first
of all I think it's brilliant
and I think that if we were living in a
linear World in other words we're one
one event follows the next logically
you're absolutely right I don't think
we'll ever get to the 2024 election
I think things are going to implode in
Washington before then
I think our economic Financial condition
is fragile it's going to come home to
roost in ugly ways now I will tell you I
don't know exactly how it will happen I
think we're going to end up in a
situation where we find out the banks
are closed for two or three weeks and
nobody can get into them you think so I
think we're going to run into something
like that yeah I also think that the
levels of violence and criminality in
our cities is so high
that it's going to spill over into other
places in society people that normally
think they can live remote from the
problem are now beginning to be touched
by the problem
then I look at this thing in Ukraine I
think Ukraine is going to lose
catastrophically it's going to be a
complete collapse and that too is going
to have an effect here at home because
people are going to say well wait a
minute everybody told us Ukraine was
winning everybody told us X Y and Z I
mean sort of the the Russian hoax on
steroids
all of those things are going to come
together or converge in some way that's
going to prevent us from reaching you
know the status quo oh another election
oh another set of campaigns and so forth
so what you're saying to me is eminently
plausible because I don't think Biden
will make it through the year I think
it'll be gone and I think everybody
knows that this person Kamala Harris
lacks the ability under any
circumstances to be president of the
United States when you say gone I mean
passing away because of this age or
merely being incapable and finally being
what is that what do they call it 25th
amendment whatever it is shuffled off
the stage I think I still say face
though they'll do it in a way to say
exactly speaking of right yeah I think
what Patrick wrote is accurate something
like that will happen
and then the the search begins and
Newsome is The Logical candidate for
them he's presiding over California
which is their poster child for the
future of America if you want to know
what the Democrats want America to
become Look at California how deeply and
dead is California what's the state of
affairs in that in that country of its
own it's catastrophe everyone who can
leave that has any Talent ability or
understanding is leaving
businesses are leaving no one wants to
be there so what are you going to end up
with a very small minority of very
wealthy people and millions of poor
people
most of whom don't even don't even
consider themselves to be Americans
so that's that's the Dream World for the
left California yeah I don't think we'll
tolerate that
so I don't think it'll ever get that far
on the national level no I could be
wrong
but I don't think we're that complacent
I also know that you get revolutionary
change when people can't eat
when the supply chains break down and
you can't deliver food when they can't
afford to buy the food when they can't
afford to buy the gasoline these things
are the catalysts for real change and
everyone's betting that the left in
charge in Washington can keep all of
this going without any Interruption
maybe they're right I don't think so
yeah I think that the Gloom in you know
what is it the the bloom and doom gloom
and doom of the chances of that for me
it's less than five percent again my
opinion you you got you we well see I
don't see that as gloom and doom I see
that as our savior
fine I by the way but here's the
challenge I I actually agree with the
fact that if they would have allowed
Powell to do his job as the Fed chair to
increase interest rates and inflate it
to the rate to decrease inflation
we would have gone through transition
phase where people would have realized
hey man this whole fake success we had
the last 12829 month economic expansion
is done but we realized everybody
including us that we thought Jerome
Powell was one of the most powerful men
in America or the world he's not
congresses Congress came out and said no
here's print some money sent into the
economy it's going to be fine don't
worry about it guys we'll uh show more
fake success to the economy holy
you know these stocks are back up these
guys are doing back again based on the
seven stocks that's coming back up you
know what
you know it's not going to happen so
he's preventing that it's like a delay
in the time bomb we're eventually going
to go through it could be 5 10 15.
someone has to eventually go through
with the right policies but whoever does
they're not going to get reelected so
you almost have to have more fake
success to get reelected it's terrible
for America it's not a good thing but
it's the structure that we've created
here's what I want to do before we wrap
this up I got the last topic I want to
talk to you've said about third party I
want to ask you about RFK gank we're
about to launch the Third
uh life I think is going to be our
fourth one live podcast at a comedy club
if uh with a guess and I'm telling you
guys it's going to sell out the moment
we announce it especially the VIP
package all of that stuff uh we'll be
sold out in no time Rob if you want to
go to the 5990 live website if you want
to be the first to find out who that
guest is going to be at our next live uh
at our Comedy Club our Cigar Lounge text
award podcast to
310-340-1132 once again text award
podcast to
310-340-1132 we had the last time we had
Rudy Giuliani and Dave Rubin it was an
entertaining debate and we did one
ourselves and we had a chance to spend a
lot of time with many of you guys we're
we're talking to some people that you're
going to want to be at this next one
here but make sure you text the word
podcast to
310-340-1132 so uh Colonel this has been
a fantastic conversation you've said
before I think it's time we need a third
party you know to rise up you're seeing
RFK I don't know if you saw him
yesterday on that town hall that he did
did you get a chance to see some of the
things he said let me tell you if you
haven't seen it highly recommend it the
answers he gave on drug addiction and he
says I remember when I fathered that I
dealt with drug addiction for 14 years
and I've seen I've lost family members
Brothers this this that and then the way
he addressed Trump he says what do you
think about the fact that many
Republicans and Trump are supporting he
says listen I love the fact that I'm
getting respect from people like that
I'm not trying to bash Biden I'm not
trying to bash Trump I'm just talking
about ideas then she talked about
fentanyl then she talked about vaccine
one of the doctors got up and challenged
him and then she says at the end so you
know what do you think about the fact
that your own family members have said
this about your family member says that
this about you in an RFK calmly turns
around and says well let me ask you this
do you mean to tell me everybody in your
family agrees with you she says no you
got me there so in every way he crushed
it yesterday on this town hall he showed
a lot of poise and he's creating a lot
of momentum with musk with Rogan with
people from the right or the left and
some people that are not Trump fans but
they're Republicans some people that are
not biting fans but they're Democrats
and
let's create a lot of momentum for
himself do you think we're at a point
right now where an RFK actually has a
chance well he'll be forced to run as an
independent because there's no way
they're going to let him be on the stage
standing next to Biden debating we all
know that's not going to be taking place
but if he runs as a third party do you
think RFK will just end up being a a
Ross Pro 2.0 or do you think he actually
stands a chance to create real momentum
and real change
well RFK Jr has an attribute that Trump
possesses it's called authenticity
when you listen to him and you talk to
him and I have it's very clear he's
telling you exactly what he thinks
that that carries enormous weight with
the American people
uh ideally you know I would like to see
those two gentlemen get together and
form a third party
I think it's time I think it could be
done you've got to get on the ballot but
that's not insurmountable obstacle
the problem I have is beyond uh you know
just get on the ballot it's the election
process itself
I mean it's corrupt
I grew up in North Philadelphia we
haven't had a clean election in that
City in 60 years
come on wake up smell the coffee Chicago
New York City Philadelphia Los Angeles
forget it now with mail-in ballots
absentee ballots I mean we're not even
talking about the software this is just
crazy it's it's nonsense you know the
French tried it it didn't work because
the whole system was corrupted
anybody who's looked at this reasonably
and objectively has said this this can't
work
the reason the states are in charge of
our electoral process
because when the Constitution was
written
people all agreed that the federal
government in 1787 had no money had no
money had no Staffing so all the states
had it so they said well we'll have to
let the States run the elections
it was a practical decision
but we've never addressed it we've never
gone back if you go to most European
States modern European States they have
strict regulations and a strict process
that requires proof of citizenship proof
of legal residence you have to show up
in person then your party affiliation is
checked if you're registered to a party
then everybody who's there from the
various parties approves you then you
get a ballot then you go you turn it can
bring the ballot back they take the
ballot they put it in the Box
that's how you run an election
we can't run an election in Georgia that
is radically different from the election
we run in Philadelphia
we've got to have them be the same
across the country and no one wants to
do that
and you know that's a constitutional
amendment we forget the Constitution was
also designed what in the 1780s
it's hardly uh relevant to the the
nation that we have today there are many
good things about it but the
Constitution is the structure of
government didn't say the Bill of Rights
Bill of Rights are sacrosanct those are
what make us As Americans they're being
trampled on left and right these days
and that needs to stop but as far as the
Constitution is concerned we've got to
rethink this whole structure of
government for the 21st century once
again nobody wants to go there but if
you have the kind of upheaval that I
think is coming we may have the
opportunity to do that
make some real changes apparently based
on that but you know some people on the
left will say all this stuff you're
talking about election uh come on
Colonel I mean we saw what happened two
months ago three months ago Fox you know
787 million dollars Dominion all these
guys that talk about elections the
biggest fine ever paid you know et
cetera et cetera and then Fox releases
Dan bongino he's no longer there and the
next person and a next person and the
next person and then the goat of fox
took a cross and they have their dispute
that's going on there so the credibility
like from the left the left is going to
use that for the election cycle the next
17 months they're gonna keep talking
about the big weapon that they got which
is one Roe v Wade the Red Wave didn't
come through because the timing of it
was terrible two
787 million dollars they're gonna say
hey if you think you're right with the
election then why the fox your Crusader
mainstream Media Company why did they
pay 787 so this whole hoax about you
know election fraud nothing like that
exists or else you want to have to pay
the fine what do you say today I think
the election
litigation was about the Dominion
software
I wasn't present there I am somewhat
familiar with it
but I can't comment on it from a legal
standpoint as to whether or not it's a
meritorious outcome
but I do know that when it comes to
absentee ballots and mail-in ballots
that's a catastrophe
that is a open door for corruption on
steroids
and if that's what we're going to see
and I think we will in all the blue
States I don't see any evidence at all
that anyone on the right can win that
election
So based on what you're saying 2024
November whatever the date is going to
end up being is most likely going to be
either a Biden a Kamala a Newsom or
Michelle well if we get to 2024 and the
left does what I think it's going to do
which is what it did the last time
they're going to win the election who do
you think is going to be the last man or
woman standing I I don't know but I
don't see this is back to the question
of what happens then yeah in other words
do you sit and take it as an American or
you say no I'm sorry I don't agree with
that
yeah ah I mean look you know there's
four things I pray about and I'm
struggling with one of them a lot lately
I pray for courage wisdom tolerance
understanding I do those are four things
I need courage to do what I'm doing on a
daily basis family business all this
stuff I need wisdom because I'm talking
to people that are smarter than me and I
want to get as much wisdom from them as
possible so God surrounding me around
smarter people than me that I'm learning
from everybody
tolerance is what I prayed for for the
longest time and then understanding to
be able to see the other side of the
argument somebody I disagree with or
disagrees with me on the tolerance side
uh it stood a point where I think
sometimes if you were to look at the
most tolerant denomination or
sect or religion you would say the most
tolerant religion is the
non-denominational Christian is who it
is okay
you would
have to say that because they're very
forgiven oh it's okay you know turn the
cheek or do this or do that okay and
we're seeing that uh the country in the
world with the least amount of lgbtq
members is Indonesia less than five
percent uh uh uh is is not not lgbtq
members Indonesia doesn't support
same-sex marriage less than five percent
of Indonesia support same-sex marriage I
think in America we're at 72 percent
give or take what the numbers that just
dropped off seven percent to it was 71
out 64 I think Christians are part of
the problem in America
I think lazy Republicans are part of the
problem in America I think Libertarians
who are like man I don't give a
what you do just leave me alone let me
make my money as much as those are all
honorable type of things to look at I
think they're all part of the problem
because they don't realize that a part
of
a what Jesus or who they admired they
had a level of intolerance to compromise
certain values and principles they were
not from the mindset of it's okay it's
okay it's okay they were like no no I'm
not crossing the line here with you you
want to do that dude but you're wrong
and I disagree with you that's what
we're going to stand where it's more
like to each his own to each his own to
each his own and this concept of being
too tolerant has gotten America to for
to go from being the greatest country in
the world where we were fear respected
admired and secretly everybody kind of
wanted to be like us of course we're
hated anytime you're number one you're
gonna be hated you know who's the most
hated football quarterback of all time
it's very easy who's the most hated
basketball player of all time it's very
easy who's the most hated country of all
time it's very easy we were able to do
something these countries for two
thousand years a thousand years couldn't
do we did it in 150 years 200 years of
course you're gonna hate that country
because it shows incompetence in your
philosophies and your ideas right so
I understand that but I kind of agree
with you where
I think the American people from those
three sects
the lazy Republicans the Libertarians
are like to each his own and to the two
tolerant Christians that are saying it's
okay to everything
I think they've kind of compromised what
these 56 men brave men that started this
country with the reason why I'm here as
an immigrant from Iran they kind of hurt
that but anyways right at the end of the
podcast I'll give you the last word here
to you uh any final thoughts you have is
there any level of optimism for the
future because if someone's listening to
this right now they're probably moving
to Singapore some of the people that are
listening to this in America they're
saying maybe I go hide in a uh you know
place in uh uh Hawaii and Kauai in the
mountains with my family of six people
should I be optimistic or pessimistic
about the future
tolerance for the Intolerable is the
path to certain destruction
it has to end that's what's given us the
criminality and is reinforcing it
everywhere secondly if there are no
standards nothing works everything falls
apart
finally I would say yes there's reason
for optimism because there are a lot
more people out there listening to us
right now who know but what you've said
is true what I've said is true and are
willing to fight when I say fight I
don't necessarily mean immediately pick
up a gun but if you can't vote your way
out at some point someone is going to
suggest we're going to have to find
another way out
and I don't think we should exclude that
possibility I'm very disappointed in the
left because there are some good people
over there that should be more sensible
they should be concerned with voter
Integrity too but they're not right now
the people running the government the
people on the left the people in the on
the Rhino right are about power and
money and that's it
we've got to get back to where what's in
the interest of the American people we
don't have that right now I think RFK Jr
believes that I know Donald Trump
believes that can they work something
out between them can we build a third
party at this point I don't know
but that's the direction we need to go
are you confident with the Santas as
well as a candidate uh I don't know the
man but when I heard him speak very
logically and say we have no vital
strategic interest in eastern Ukraine
there's no reason for us to become
involved in a war there and then two
days later say oh I was wrong I guess
it's really important that we be there
it tells me he's donor focused
I don't want anybody who's donor Focus
Donald Trump was never donor focused
very interesting well there you have it
folks uh we're going to put the link
below to your most recent book that came
out a couple months ago margin of
Victory five battles that changed the
face of modern uh War uh Colonel
somebody put a super chat in here let me
just give credit to the person that
asked this question I'll ask you from
you as well it's gay is uh uh Joe Diaz
he asked what a weird name but he asked
the question about uh Colonel would you
be willing to return to the pbd podcast
and debate someone like a Peter zahan
who disagrees with you
would I be willing to do that sure I can
if that if people think that would be
useful okay fantastic so we'll reach out
to Peter rob if you want to make a note
of that to see if that's something
because I think that that would be
that would be definitely uh he has
certain views that are very different
than yours the audience will be able to
win their uh and FYI we had roughly 120
000 concurrent people 120 000 people
listen to us the last two hours this is
going to get a few million views uh on
the conversation we had with you uh gang
for those of you guys that uh are are
from the business standpoint of the
audience last time we did our live and
we had 200 people in attendance 85
percent of people that raise their hands
were business owners small business
owners to the small business owner
community
the executives the founders the
salespeople those would be guys that are
running businesses we are hosting uh
Vault conference August 30th to
September 2nd with myself Tom Brady Mike
Tyson will kidero from 11 Madison the
book he wrote unreasonable hospitality
to discuss different strategies to grow
your business a great place for
proximity to meet other people like
yourself especially at a time like this
to know what strategies are working
today not what worked in 2021 not what
worked in 2022 or 2018 but what's
working today and Beyond we are running
a special for Fourth of July it's buy
one get one free grab your spouse grab
your business partner grab your partners
uh running mates that you have get
yourself two tickets it's only Fourth of
July special that we're running here get
registered we'll spend three days
together in Miami at the Diplomat Rob
let's put the link below where they can
get registered for this and I'm looking
forward to seeing yourself with your
partners there to spend some time with
myself Tom Brady Tyson and will get Era
Colonel once again thank you for coming
out this was fantastic appreciate you
have a great weekend everybody take care
bye bye-bye